Michael you said you weren't going to
come to LA until you had that acting
real yeah there were a few things that I
made a list of things I needed before I
went to LA one was a better resume
so I wasn't got some credits to was an
acting real because I knew how many
actors were out here I didn't know
exactly how many actors were out here
but I knew that there were a lot more
than New York
so I was in my mind I was like how am I
gonna stand out amongst this whole sea
of actors beginners advanced you know
whatever how am I going to stick out and
be noticed by a manager and agency well
get a real make a real make a highlight
tape of stuff you've done so you can
show people because guess what a
headshot is a headshot it's a picture of
you I could you know you could take a
picture of some guy walking down the
street called a headshot and he can say
I'm an actor sag after he'd be lie and
say it doesn't really do much unless you
look like Brad Pitt you know I don't
look like Brad Pitt so how do I
differentiate myself I have to show my
acting talent how do you do that invite
people to a show yeah are people gonna
come with them probably not maybe you
know maybe you get lucky you gets you
know maybe out of 20 emails you send the
cast directors who want to come to your
your showcase maybe you get one that
comes but how can I effectively send out
a package with all my stuff in it that
everyone will at least have the access
to not necessarily click on cuz you get
spam on every day you can't get an email
from someone oh I mean this thing okay
delete but what if you package it with a
real a resume a website and all your
contact information and your pictures on
one web page what if you do that so the
goal was make a website have you real on
it have your photos have news like a
news feed of what stuff you're doing to
say hey Here I am here's all my stuff
take it or leave it and I was gonna and
I did that literally the day before I
left LA I had launched my website
I did that on purpose to just have a
what do they call it like a burrata not
a barrage but have a I don't know the
word oh like a day and date of you
coming out town yeah exactly but they
have like just like um I'm not fine the
word but just I wanted to make it an
all-in-one assault almost like an
assault of Michael gallant a not bits
and pieces not you know it's all who is
this kid he's brand-new no one really
knows him but here's his stuff and it
worked I got here I sent out all these
emails to all his managers with the real
a resume that website all professionally
done thank God for my creative team
because I can't do this stuff I wasn't
Eddie make my website I didn't make my
real I I had an amazing team of friends
really talented friends you did this for
me they're professionals at what they do
but they also happen to be friends so
let's go back as if that sounds great a
creative team but how did you
so you knew so and so did website she
knew so and so did reals how many times
did you meet with them oh god to them
the real was a two three year process
along okay of getting clips together
going through them highlighting what
what we're gonna use what we're not
going to use I had you know yeah I had
two editors working on my real then I
had a graphic designer to make a website
which I paid for well you know enfold
but he was a friend I played soccer with
a really talented guy extremely talented
people and these people were able to
make me you know package me in this one
on a website and make me look marketable
and that's what you have to do you have
to do that
because there's too many actors out
there to just come to LA and say go to a
manager to say hey here's my here's my
head shot
I'm working on my real right and I think
when you when you show all that it it
also sends a message that you know you
get work done or you kind of do what you
say you're going to do it's complete
right you you know yeah are your credits
are you working on you know
x-men for no maybe not but you're at
least you understand what the business
is about by doing that because you're
you have to it's a business you have to
be a marketable human being right you
have to appeal to the masses how do you
do that
you have to at least have a portfolio
that kids can you know get to a lot of
people so I thought the website would do
that with a real that packages me you
know into one it's just clicking you
know gave them if gated made I mean it's
very easy for managers and agents to
access what I've done and I think actors
they don't do enough of that so when you
got here how did you get access to those
people's information IMDB I went on IMDB
Pro which you can pay for it's like I
don't sixty bucks a month I can't
believe I'm saying this at this is very
good information actress out there and I
went yeah I'm just gonna do it I went
through you can actually sort through on
I'm you pro and rank that managers and
agents one to there's like twenty
thousand of them and I went through for
three weeks three weeks stayed in my
apartment had a glass of wine
occasionally just to relieve the stress
and tension and went through and sort it
out whose contact info like I have
because sometimes they don't list you
know sometimes the emails are there
sometimes they're not I emailed
everybody anyway I didn't care because
my mentality was I have nothing to lose
and I went through and I emailed the top
100 managers in Los Angeles and I got
responses and a lot of them were funny
they were like we don't usually do this
but would you take a meeting with us
like yeah of course I would take a
meeting with you and I was fortunate to
take about eight meetings and got offers
from about from four people and I signed
with with one which was the best one and
this has been within how much time four
months four months how long with it was
this email and what did it say it was
one page and it was extremely candid and
honest hey my name is Michael Galante
here's my real here's my resume here's a
website here's some photos I would love
to work with you let me know what you
think it was extremely honest and just
to the point there was no BS I didn't
really talk about myself you know why
because the website did it
the real did it that's the beautiful
thing about a real when you have that
you don't have to talk about yourself
because once you start talking about
yourself people tune out come on I mean
we're on the street and you start
talking about yourself you hear someone
talk it's like okay you could be telling
the truth or you could not be telling
truth you know you don't know you have
no idea you can't fake a real it's there
you press play and those are images of
you on a show or in a commercial that's
not that's not BS so I was it was all
planned out so you said the real was
what two years in the making
yeah well no if you think about it it
was of all the time I was in New York
about five six years in the making
took all the footage compiled it into my
reels come along five minutes
it's a great real it's funny though
isn't it six years of work into five
minutes and so what made you choose
certain scenes I'd hired a my editor
Mark Odgers who's one of the most
talented people I know in this world and
he he was like used this don't use this
this is terrible this is good we're
gonna use that he just turned it into me
until it a little little movie and
that's what people watched when I sent
out to managers and agents and they're
like okay okay I'm gonna call this kid
you